CHET HAASE: So today let's
talk about animation.
There was a lot of animation
facilities added in Android 3,
the Honeycomb release.
There's a whole animation
package and that package in
those classes have been
enhanced over time in
subsequent releases.
So we're going to talk about
some of the stuff that was
added in 3.0, as well as some
stuff that was added in
Android 4.1 Jelly Bean.
In particular, we're going
to talk about the layout
transition class.
It's a little known class.
It's actually used a lot
internally in some of the
applications that we
ship on Android.
And it's something that we
created to make animation much
easier for you.
I like to think about animation
all the time.
But I realize that maybe some
other developers don't.
So if we can make it easier
and easier for you to get
animated facilities within
your application without
spending a great deal of time
and thought on it, then that's
a good thing.
So let's talk about
layout transition.
First of all, we'll start with
the base application that
doesn't have animations in it.
And let's look at
the code here.
So we have a simple class
that I've created.
It's a custom view that
I call colored view.
And it has two states.
It has an expanded and
a compressed state.
And when it's first added into
its container, it's in a
compressed.
And it's going to be
50 pixels high.
And when it's expanded, it's
going to be 200 pixels high.
And we can simply change those
layout params so that when we
click on this thing it can
expand or it can contract.
And as we can see,
we do something
really interesting here.
We basically randomize a color
to make it a colored view so
that you can actually
tell what the
bounds of the view are.
And then we allow you
to click on the view
and expand or contract.
And we can take a look at the
demo over on the screen to the
right and see how this works.
So we have two buttons up at the
top, which add new views
of different randomized
colors or remove
views in the container.
And if we click on one of these
views, it will expand
and contract as we toggle the
clicks back and forth.
And we can see the other
activity logic up
here that does that.
We have an add button
and a remove button.
We have the container.
And we start out with
two views that
we add to the container.
And then when you click on the
add button we add a view.
And when you click on
the remove button
well we remove a view.
OK, not terribly interesting.
I don't think I'd be
doing this video if
this was all it was.
But now let's actually
add some animation.
You can notice that when we
add an item it just blinks
into place.
When we remove it, it
blinks out of place.
And when we click, it just
automatically expands or contracts.
That's not what I would call
a nice transition.
It's certainly not
a nice animation.
So what can we do about that?
Well the first thing we can do
is add a facility that was
added in Android 3.0, as I said
before, called layout
transition.
And there are a couple different
ways to do this,
both of which are simple.
But the easiest way is just to
tell the container where you
want animations to run
automatically to animate the
layout changes.
So let's add an attribute
here that is android
animate layout changes.
And we'll set it to true.
We'll go ahead and save this.
We'll run the application
again.
And watch over on the demo
screen as it comes up.
So it starts out the same.
But now when we add an item,
you'll see we actually get
animated behavior, just
from that one line of
code in the XML file.
Things slide out of place
to make room and then
fade in or fade out.
So you can see as we add items
everything around it moves out
of the way, and then we
fade the new item in.
As we remove an item, we fade
out the item, and then
everything moves around it to
compress the space that was
freed up by the item
going away.
But when we click on the items
to expand and contract,
obviously those are
not animating.
Those are just popping into
their before and after state.
This was the behavior as
it was in Honeycomb.
You could easily add this
one line of code in XML.
You could add something very
similar to set a layout
transition object on a container
if you wanted to do
it in code instead
of the XML file.
So now we go to Android 4.1
Jelly Bean release.
And we've got a new facility
in there that allows you to
actually animate more.
So let's see how that works.
So if we come down to the end
of our on create method, and
we actually get a reference to
the layout transition object
that we created.
So you can say layout
transition equals
container.getlayoutTransition.
OK, we know there's
one on there.
Because we set it in
the resource file.
And similarly, we could have
set this in code instead of
the resource file.
Anyway, we know that there's
a transition there.
And we can say transition.enabl
eTransitionType(
LayoutTransition.CHANGING) So
there's a new type of transition
that we're going to
take advantage of
in this release.
Now if we run this file
again, demo pops up on
the handy demo screen.
And now let's see
what it's like.
So as before, when we
add items, we get a
nice animated behavior.
Or when we remove them, we get
a nice animated behavior.
And when we click them, we also
get an animated behavior.
So what we've told the layout
transition object is to
animate not only the default
animations that it knows about
when items go away or come
into being, but also when
anything in the container
changes the layout.
So anything that happens that
causes a layout on the
container, we'll make it look
at all of its items and say,
OK, where are you now?
And how big are you?
And where are you and how big
are you after the layout runs?
And then it sets up animations
internally to animate those
changes, basically animating
the bounds of the objects.
So kind of nifty, and the best
part is, this was what, three
lines of code?
It's one line of code just to
enable the layout transition
on a container.
And then it's another couple
of lines of code, or even
effectively one line of code
to say, I also want this
change in behavior.
Now we added this facility in
4.1 to allow this behavior,
but we did not change the
default behavior.
Because it could have been
unexpected if people were
using layout transition
already.
So instead we added it as a
facility that you could add
after the fact, saying OK enable
a layout transition and
also enable the changing
capability on that.
And one of the things to
realize about layout
transition is that these could
also be custom animations.
You can check this out on
API demos if you'd like.
There's some demo showing custom
animations as well as
the default animations.
But the default ones basically
give you kind of what would be
expected, which is when an item
comes into being we move
everything out of the way,
and then we fade it in.
And when it goes away, we fade
the thing out, and then we
move everything around it.
If you want something different,
then you can
certainly create that.
So go ahead and check out layout
transition and the 4.1
Jelly Bean release.
And please play with it and add
cool animated effects to
your application.
Thanks.